all the ladies get your cameras out
we're gonna set the record straight here
when i say go everybody whip out that
dick girl
white dude sit down down
quickly hey some of them still standing
y'all must be italian
i don't like looking at my dick anymore
my dick looks distinguished it's oh
that old looking dick it's got salt and
pepper hair
all around it
my dick looks like morgan friedman in
the 90s
without the dots
my dick narrates dave pulled me out and
started jerking me around
and jerking me around but not with the
same vickers when he was young
he and i both knew nothing was coming
out um
here's uh this guy says i'm six inches
plus flaccid
and just shy of eight hard with a
six-inch girth
here's a problem i have every time i get
a full body scan
going through security at an airport i
have to get patted down because my dick
shows up
um i have to buy relaxed fit pants
because anything tight in the crotch
region gives a good outline
anytime doppler radar goes off they're
like we have a disturbance in india
never mind it's davis yeah i want to
know
do you think you have a bigger hog than
that guy right there
there's one way we can find it
7 500 patrons you suck our causes
wait for it bro wait for it wait for it
wait for it
he sucks your dick it's 69 and whoever
gives up first
okay whoever gives up whoever gags first
i'm just saying uh go to church a lot
guys
i would think we can have
this is the way i measure my deck yeah
you know the cable vision remote yeah
yeah you take the batteries out of that
[ __ ] because it's not the size that's
how you use it right
now
no it's not it's neither one
it doesn't matter how big it is or how
you use it
because by the time you find out how
small it is and how terrible i am with
it
it's too late i came
what do you think of that my
personality is gonna keep me out of the
second date no matter
how well i perform you'll tell all your
friends but i don't give a [ __ ] i don't
know your friends and besides
how much [ __ ] do you get on referral
none not even a lick
yours is just fine honey don't worry
about it really it's not the size that's
how you use it and
yours is perfect really it's fine don't
even worry
i almost believed you too angel till i
found your vibrator in your panty drawer
looks like a foot long it looks like
you'd hold tennis balls in the [ __ ]
thing
if mine's so perfect why didn't you buy
the three and a half inch crooked one
with the hanky balls
because they don't sell it that's why
and if they do sell it it's attached to
a key ring because it's a [ __ ]
joke y'all ever walked into your parents
say what you ever walked in on your
parents hell no
no but i would hear him i hear my
parents [ __ ] all the time oh my god
all the time my dad making no noise
mom like a [ __ ] gentleman my dad is a
professional what about his business
i don't wanna i don't wanna hear mama
shots please don't donate
[Applause]
oh
i thought you were saying laddie not
larry it just kind of sounds like that
with your accent
we like somebody my brother would always
try to knock on the door like he didn't
know what the [ __ ] they were doing
my brother knock on the door with
concern he'd be like are you okay mom
no she's not she's getting that hammer
okay
ragnarok that's what they call my dad
[ __ ] ragnarok
[Music]
drag that rock god damn god anyway
i'm aroused at andy's place when we
first like started getting cool
you live with your folks and then it's
like two in the morning we're just
working on like a script without
whatever but then his dad just walks out
with a shirt oh no
draws just dick hanging out like winnie
the pooh
just yeah
larry schultz big dick energy
and then he saw me and he was like oh
and he like kind of kind of tried to
cover it up but like
he didn't really give up he was like
you're in my house
dope though is like when you walk in
with just the shirt on he had that white
tee always sleep in a white tee no
drawers because he might have to [ __ ]
the [ __ ] in the middle of the night
right so
white no draws right walk out the room
go to the bathroom we're chilling there
dick out right
sometimes if he was really tired he'd
just wave he wouldn't acknowledge it at
all
other times what he would do is he'll
say what if you lift the shirt
up he goes oh oh and he take the shirt
and he pull it down over his dick
and that would just expose his ass even
more so he just walked by it was just
cheeks flapping it's always a strange
day the first time you see your father's
dick
your dad got bigger at that point yes he
had a
way bigger smaller over the generation
like real talk real talk my dad got a
bigger dick than me my dad's dick
fat and [ __ ] yo my dad's dick is
crazy bro his dick was
nuts yeah it's crazy i haven't seen my
dad's dick i've seen your dad's dick
with with your sexuality you're born
you grow up you discover you like
same-sex relationships and that's it
you're gay
okay but being gay to be the same as
being fat
you'd have to be born be straight grow
up knowing you're straight
but gradually and consciously wean
yourself on to [ __ ]
oh happy 16th birthday son
um this is raul
suck his [ __ ] sorry father
stuck his [ __ ] 16 now suck his [ __ ] i
i'm heterosexual
all with his new fangled words suck his
[ __ ] come on
i i don't like [ __ ] father doesn't like
[ __ ] how do you know if you've never
tried it ah
suck his [ __ ] i got suck a one [ __ ] suck
oh that's not sucking it that's playing
with it put it in your mouth
but oh
have a go you might like it oh it's not
so bad is it
i [ __ ] love these
if that happened then being gay would be
the same as being fat
but it doesn't so it's not okay
i got a hairy chest it's okay if you
have a hairy chest be proud of it i'll
admit i do do one thing
a little extra that maybe you agree with
or don't i don't care but i do it
i give myself like a body fade
i do it's clippers i start here
with a zero and a one
two three it's nice it's very gradual
it's very
looks like i got a receding ball line or
something it's very
it's right now it's great today why are
you acting like i'm the only guy in here
who's ever shaved his package why why
why is this happening
you shave it buddy you're damn right i
do
and the real reason to be honest with
you i shave down there to make my thing
look bigger
because i'll be honest with you god
wasn't kind of the indian man you know
he gave us a lot of things he was like
all right here's what's going to happen
indians
gonna be great with computers
okay you'll be able to survive in the
worst human conditions imaginable
okay you'll be able to leave those
conditions go anywhere in the world and
become successful
fantastic and what about penises
sorry buddy average
and he called the black people over come
here for a minute i want to talk to you
listen people are going to be messing
with you for hundreds of years
here's a little extra penis i don't
worry about it i took it from the
indians it's okay
[Music]
um all right size issues oh jesus here
we go again
here we go again maybe you need a
motorcycle all right
size it's a que paso bilonardo
hola villanado
we all know your disability um to read
pop
properly well you know what you don't
even have to write a sentence properly
half of this [ __ ]
is i get too far in front of myself and
the other half you guys don't know how
to write a [ __ ] sentence
we all know your disability to read
properly is that even written correctly
or am i a [ __ ] again we all know you
have a disability when it comes to
reading properly isn't that how it's
supposed to be
someone i don't know [ __ ] so i'm going
to give it my best shot to keep it
very short look at you coming with the
arrogance like
you have all life figured out right you
got something tattooed on your rib
um as you may have read the subject
title of this email you may already know
where this is heading yeah you seem
pretty cocky for a guy with a little
dick
um he says i recently got into an
argument with my girlfriend who i've
who i've been with for a little more
than two and a half years
where she told me that she wished i had
a bigger dick
oh man uh yeah that relationship is over
dude that relationship is over one of
two ways
either one she's just trying to be so
[ __ ] mean to you
that you break up with her because she
doesn't want to be the bad guy
or she's just such a [ __ ]
self-involved human being that she
doesn't realize
like how mean that is they'd be like you
said yeah i like you i wish your tits
were bigger that would just be the
meanest [ __ ] thing why would you say
that to somebody
that you cared about that's a horrible
thing to say sir
you know what you started off as an
arrogant [ __ ] now i'm feeling bad for
you
uh dude that's not the mother of your
kids
just take the dick out of the equation
what if you just said your nose is too
big that's just [ __ ] uh that's
that's that's that's just something a
terrible person says
she goes i was shocked to hear this and
didn't know what to say there's nothing
to say there's nothing you can do about
it
this is the first time she ever
mentioned my penis size also the first
time in my life by the way i guess
anybody's ever brought it up to be
honest
i don't know that i'm not well endowed
with my 5.5 inch rocket
you're a little below average sir i'm
not gonna lie to you now i'm being me
you know you can grab the rim but you
can't stuff at home if you know what i
mean
um and i did have a little uh
have insecurities about it in the past
but learned to accept it and moved on
i never heard any of my former bed
partner girls complain
and the sex was usually great um
i know that it may sound ridiculous but
those few words were heartbreaking to
hear
and put a big giant stain on my
confidence yeah it's a terrible thing
that she said
i haven't felt like having sex ever
since and she made
oh ever since she made that remark and i
am afraid it's going to be a while i
haven't spoken to her
since the argument since i work a lot we
don't live together
i know it's a stupid thing to be upset
about no it isn't sir you're a hundred
percent in the right
100 the right and he goes and i usually
don't really care about penis sizes
but but hearing that you're small from
your own girlfriend
is a whole other story i'm particular
typically not that guy that gets back in
her
by pointing out her physical flaws but i
don't know where
to go from here uh it's even been
difficult
texting with her what do i do bill got
any advice okay you said you don't know
where to go from here
i can tell you exactly where to go right
out her front [ __ ] door
that's it it's a wrap sir it's a wrap
okay
now listen i'm not saying that she's
wrong
for wanting a bigger dick okay
like she needs more to satisfy her or
whatever or she just wants to go out and
bang some [ __ ] big dick dude
at this point all right
you know but her tact is wrong
okay you you accepted yourself which is
one of the greatest things you can do
that leads towards being happy every day
which leads you to treating the people
around you
respectfully which leads them to
treating you respectfully which leads to
more happiness
she [ __ ] with the core of your
happiness you know
you felt good about yourself she pointed
out something
and made you feel horrible about
yourself it's one of the worst [ __ ]
things she could have done
as far as mentally to you and
and right now the last thing you want to
do is go out and say the same thing to
her
all right if you really want to do just
paraphrase what the [ __ ] i just said
it just just i don't know and i would
just leave it at that i g
and the childish thing to do this is
what if you really want to get her back
just saying the challenges thing for me
to do would point out
some some of your physical flaws and the
great thing is is you leave it ambiguous
okay and i guarantee you she's going to
be in a bathroom mirror staring at
herself
if you want to get me okay
but um you know what this but i gotta
tell you something what's even better
you gotta have this what's known as the
self-esteem breakup
okay which you're totally in the right
here and you just say listen
all right what you said to me i thought
i used to feel good about myself
and what you said to me mess with the
core of my own my own happiness
and how i feel about myself
and that's not what i'm looking for in a
girlfriend
or a potential wife and uh
i just can't see you ever being a good
mother
if you would say something like that
just something along those lines i i
don't i keep going mean don't go mean
uh whatever the [ __ ] i just said i was
just trying to paraphrase what the [ __ ]
i said but
dude this this is you should feel good
about yourself all right
you know you're not a porn star but
you're also you know you're not like uh
you're not what she's making you out to
be here all right
that's it you still you're still in the
game sir okay you're not part of the
starting five hey neither am i
you know but you and i we come off that
bench okay we're the kind of guys
we're the guys that go in the corners
right
[Music]
um yeah man that's that's you're 100
advice my advice would be
that this girl is is not anywhere near
the level of maturity she needs to be
and might never even get to that level
um the only redeeming thing that i can
say to her is she has such a difficult
time
doing what she wants to do in life that
maybe she wanted to break up with you
for a while and she didn't know how to
do it and it was building up and then
there was just an argument and then she
just said that
or i don't know have you said anything
to her
i have no idea um
oh it's funny he says uh thanks for the
weekly podcast
you have no idea what it means to me see
you in amsterdam
well from what this other guy was
writing sir there's a bunch of uh
beautiful ladies out there in amsterdam
um yeah dude the [ __ ] they're all riding
bikes they're in great goddamn shade go
on go get
go go find yourself a sweetheart alright
alright there you go